Netflix is you is currently one of its
highest view TV shows after its first
season and rightly so the fascinating
drama gives a fantastic insight into the
mind of a stalker that is just so
charming he actually convinces the
audience that he's the good guy after a
huge cliffhanger viewers are naturally
anxious to find out when the show's
second season will air and what will
happen in it so throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the released
information on it so far there will be
heavy spoilers here in regards to season
1 so if you haven't had a chance to
watch it yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to you season 1 ended with Joel
murdering back after she tried to escape
from his basement book page after
framing Hill psychiatrist dr. Nicki whom
Beck had been having an affair with it
seemed like the character was in the
clear that was until his ex-girlfriend
Candace walked back into the bookshop
and said they needed to have a talk
Candace had been thought dead the entire
season by viewers so this shocked
revelation felt like a real gut punch so
what do we know about season 2 so far
well Netflix has acquired the show from
lifetime who must be kicking themselves
and this is the first season that they
will be handling creatively production
is due to start mid-year so we should
expect to see it back on the platform
close to Christmas again this season is
due to be set in LA with Joe journeying
there against his better judgment
co-creator Sarah gamble recently told
cosmopolitan in an interview that Joe's
gone to hate it he's not there for fun
he's in LA not because he's been dying
to live in LA but he's there for a
reason that becomes clear in the first
episode he had a lot of judgment about
New Yorkers around him and the LA people
around him are 10 times worse with Joe
doing this reluctantly I would imagine
this is due to the fact that he is on
the run and needs to get out of New York
at some point in the season also the big
aspect is candy
is 100% back and is no longer just a
hallucination the series will likely
showcase the two lovers past and give
reason to why she went AWOL whilst back
is not confirmed as returning her two
best friends are this may tie into the
investigation from peaches parents which
centers around Joe in addition to this I
would even hazard a guess that BAC will
be back in some form or another either
because she's not dead as we never saw
her body or in the form of a
hallucination
similar to Candice Paco's mother has
been confirmed to return so it seems
likely that Paco will - and this may tie
into her boyfriend's murder which Joe
carried out in season one so is there
anything that you've heard about season
two of you that I've missed and are you
excited for the show's return comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
season one's ending which will be linked
after this video this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]